what's up wisecrack jared again
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom has been
absolutely obliterated by critics and
audiences alike calling out its unfunny
characters lack of originality and worst
of all the unforgivable sin of not
enough Jeff Goldblum now there's a lot
to be said about how the latest Jurassic
movies haven't amazed us in the same way
that Spielberg's 1993 original did but
at least Jurassic world seemed somewhat
aware of its inherent shortcomings let's
be honest no one's impressed by a
dinosaur anymore but the Jurassic world
follow up falling Kingdom shows how far
the franchise has fallen on paper though
it actually seems to have something
going for it because unlike its 2015
predecessor the movie actually tries to
develop the underlying moral question of
the original it moves from should
dinosaurs be brought back to life -
should we consciously let dinosaurs go
extinct again no one can deny that
fallen Kingdom looks absolutely stunning
at times but despite the bajillion zuv
dollars thrown at the special effects
budget the movie is still so boring so
why aren't we more immersed than ever
well let's find out in this wisecrack
edition on Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
what went wrong and spoilers ahead if
anyone cares let's briefly recap for
those of you who've already left this
movie go extinct in their minds after
the destruction of Jurassic world at the
claws of the indominus rex the dinosaurs
are left to roam the island freely once
more however fast forward three years
and a volcano on the island is about to
blast Littlefoot and ducky into
extinction
once again oh and and Claire don't why
you forgot their names - don't want this
to happen and join a rescue team in an
effort to save as many of the species as
they can so the stage is set presenting
us with perhaps the most action-packed
high-stakes situation in Jurassic Park
history while simultaneously evoking the
main ethical and moral questions that
made the original so beloved should we
take responsibility for our own
creations and save the dinosaurs from
their second extinction or should we bow
down to mother nature and let the
volcano deal with our incompetence once
and for all so let's see what we got
here
developing themes from the original
Czech suite digital effects in action
check everyone's favorite killing
machine check
so what could possibly go wrong life
finds away by contrast the original
Jurassic Park came out 25 whole years
ago at a time when CGI was still in its
infancy so it shouldn't surprise anyone
that the handful of computerized
dinosaurs featured in the original
aren't exactly up to par with today CGI
so why is it then that the Aged action
sequences in Jurassic Park still feel
more engaging and memorable than the
visually superior set pieces of falling
Kingdom to answer this question we need
to go back to the man who started it all
Steven Spielberg in his own words
Spielberg avoided making just another
monster movie this was not going to be a
genre of horror science fiction fantasy
he didn't want Jurassic Park to revolve
around scary monsters chasing after
helpless one-dimensional characters
instead he wanted the film to focus on
the journey of a group of relatable
characters who have to deal with the
reality that dinosaurs have been
suddenly brought back to life for
Spielberg the original Jurassic Park was
a human story not a dinosaurs eating
people story it's not just about the
visual spectacle of witnessing a man
getting eaten off the toilet by a
dinosaur but the emotional journeys of
the characters it's with this knowledge
in mind that we uncover why this is
infinitely less Eon inducing than this
insanity take for instance the now
iconic t-rex scene in Jurassic Park
just as our protagonists are passing by
the enclosure of the king of all
dinosaurs the parks power grid is
suddenly turned off leaving be my t-rex
free to go wherever she pleases the
biggest man-eating animal in the world
escapes and our protagonists are the
first prey to cross her path what
follows is a roughly 6 minute action
suspense sequence in which our
protagonists try their best not to get
II seem pretty straightforward right
well yes and no even though the
characters trying to survive is what is
literally happening on the screen it's
what's going on under the surface that
matters from a story perspective it
isn't as much about the introduction
the t-rex as it is about the protagonist
dr. Alan Grant learning to become a
father at the beginning of the film were
introduced to the idea that Dr Grant is
not exactly the kind of guy who lets his
nephew win at Super Smash Brothers in
fact Spielberg really tries to hammer
home that Grant doesn't like kids and
would rather remain obsessed with the
dead past than thinking about creating
life in the future kids have one of
those
we're also briefly notified that
Hammonds daughter of the mom of these
two kids is going through a divorce you
told me that hammy can't even bother to
see me he had to leave early he wants to
be with these daughters she's getting at
the door well I understand that so even
though we're all just anxiously waiting
to see Newman get skeeted on by a
Dilophosaurus the stage is set for the
underlying theme of the movie family
let's head back to that pivotal scene
Donald the only adult in the car with
the kids suddenly feels his breakfast
burrito twirling around in his bowels
and decides to dip out and head to the
nearest bathroom the kids having been
abandoned by yet another male authority
figure are alone and panicking dr. grant
immediately realizes he has to make a
decision he can either remain still and
decrease his chances of getting eaten or
act in a selfless somewhat fatherly
manner Alan one repression a father
instincts zero it's moments like this
that elevate the action from a mere will
they survive - how will the characters
grow as they try to survive so when good
ol Rexy breaks through her own glass
ceiling at the start of the sequence
it's not just mere spectacle its action
and service of character growth and
theme it engages us not just because it
looks cool but because we can relate to
the story on a personal level
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom on the
other hand has almost none of this sure
at the start of the story were
reintroduced to be moral and ethical
questions surrounding the survival or
demise of the dinosaurs on the island do
dinosaurs deserve for the same
protections given to other endangered
species or should they be left to
but we learn next to nothing about the
internal lives of the protagonists so
even though its main action set piece
might be visually far more impressive
than the t-rex scene without this
underlying layer
what-you-see-is-what-you-get Chris Pratt
running away from dinosaurs and lava it
might be a feast for the eyes but it
starves us emotionally let's look at
another example from the original right
after the t-rex breakout scene Allen has
to try and save Timmy who's still
trapped in this car unfortunately for
them this tree can't hold the cars
weight and it's about to drop and crush
our protagonist to death in fallen
kingdom we see a similar action sequence
unfold when Claire and Franklin have to
climb a ladder to escape a hungry
dinosaur who's only barely being held
back by a dripping wall of lava doesn't
seem too different from the falling car
setup right well the difference here is
that this moment in Jurassic Park isn't
just a random moment for the sake of
suspense but that it again serves to
develop the theme of the story just that
coming out of a treehouse is dead at the
Doubletree mr. Allen is again forced
into a position in which he has to act
as a father in order to save Timmy's
life and even the climax of the sequence
with Allen and Timmy miraculously
surviving the car falling down on them
serves a purpose instead of just being a
cop-out cliche to trick the audience
into thinking that the characters have
died
this moment is used to show the
metaphorical rebirth of Allen like a
dinosaur from an egg
he's no longer the dinosaur obsessed
child averse man he once was but instead
has embraced the possibility of being a
future father now that's an action scene
packed with meaning and yeah you've
probably guessed it fallen Kingdom has
nothing like this like Alan and Timmy
Claire and Franklin also barely escaped
their deaths in the nick of time but
that's all there is to it nothing about
the characters or their relationship has
changed and so there's no meaning to it
beyond survival so what could have been
a visualization of their inner growth
ends up being another vapid spectacle
since the characters remain virtually
the same so the reason why this action
scene still grabs us 25 years after its
inception
is not just because it first introduced
us to the t-rex but because of how it
uses action in service of the underlying
story it tells two stories at the same
time one that excites us and adds
suspense and one that people can truly
relate to combine the two and you have
an action sequence that engages audience
across time no matter how prehistoric
its visuals all the pieces were there to
make a thoroughly enjoyable and
memorable film perhaps equaling or even
surpassing the original a film with the
same sort of engaging emotional subtext
as the original combined with the
advancement in digital effects could
have made for something truly special
and yes I'm sure some people had a blast
watching Chris Pratt run away from
dinosaurs and giant melting rocks but
will these scenes still truly live on in
the minds of those same people 25 years
from now needless to say we have doubts
at least Trevor oh and Bayona made sure
that the series wouldn't devolve further
into a mindless monster movie by
repeating the same mistake Spielberg
made in the lost world
Oh now if you're sad that all the real
dinosaurs went the way the fidgets
spinner
don't be there's actually plenty of
prehistoric monsters that still roam the
earth and to the best of my knowledge
none of them will go all noumenon you
take for example the great salamander
who for the past 160 million years has
remained relatively unchanged and
there's a version of it that's so nasty
that early American settlers named it
after hell spawn but to learn all about
that you got to check out the newest
video from Animal Logic if you love
learning about the amazing animals we
share the planet with and I really think
you're gonna like animal logic Danyelle
combines her explanatory powers with her
scientific illustrations to teach you
everything you've ever wanted to know
about animals from the antelope that
looked like they're straight out of Star
Wars to wasps that I honestly never want
to see in my life they're disgusting
if you love animals as much as I do
click here to check out animal logic
thanks for watching guys peace